[Music]
how did this world get so broken
hello
you're gonna bring everyone back i want
to help
i too wish to join this drone but
hickory the world's broken you can't
trust anyone maybe the world's broken
because you don't trust anyone
[Music]
it's a difficult thing for her to be
able to develop this trust because she
grew up in this broken world
and it really was because of the
distrust that people had
that led to the breaking of her family
and the breaking of her world stand up
how do you build trust between each
other
what's dripping deplo nemari what
happened if
that trust was broken and you have to
restore it again and take a chance on
people in order to build something for
the greater good
take them
i think forgiveness and trust are always
essential
and i don't know i mean i guess if
everyone else's life is anything like
mine i'm constantly messing up and
constantly needing forgiveness and i
think right i think the more we can just
be open about our messy human stuff and
the more we can just forgive each other
i think the world will just be kinder
for sure i really do believe that
[Music]
riot she didn't start off that way
[Music]
pariah it took a dragon and i think for
most of us
it takes this sort of magical
transcendent trust
and seeing the beauty of other people
and other cultures to get past that
bridge i don't know why they chose me
it could have been any of us
all i know
is i trusted them
and they trusted me
and so
everyone give me your gems
we can still put it together it can
still work see sue's gone raya we don't
have her magic it's not about her magic
it's about trust what i mean that's why
it worked that's why we can do it too
by doing the one thing sisu wanted us to
do what my boy wanted us to do to
finally trust each other and fix this
but we have to come together
please
if the what she's done we'll never trust
her
then let me take the first step
[Music]
right now
the most important theme to me
is our main theme which is is trust and
um and how
difficult it is to build trust and
maintain trust over time here
oh
really from one dragon nerd
to another
thank you devlog
for raya her journey is trying to figure
out what it takes
to be able to have a conversation a
relationship or a connection with
someone that you
normally wouldn't expect to be able to
have that connection with my girl ryan
and i are going to fix the world
bring everyone back
ryan the last dragon
it's a movie about
[Music]
the importance of working together
please
let me help you despite our differences
trusting one another and coming together
for the greater good
and it comes with this
deep respect for the family we have
and for the family we create
a big part of what makes this movie so
special come on
have you eaten yet
is it is a superhero movie
but unlike most hero movies where raya
draws her superpower from isn't from
like a radioactive bite or coming from a
different distant planet it's from very
specifically her ability to trust
connecting with other people
people that she might not agree with
and i think that that's something that
makes her very unique
for me the best thing about that is
taking the first step i think
it's so easy to say and really hard to
do especially when you're living in a
world where there is loss and there is
pain and there is suffering and you've
been hurt and you have evidence to show
that hey sometimes things don't work out
that great yeah and for her to still be
able to give up everything for the idea
of something better
running out of time is
something that i want to try and do all
the time
it's the ultimate form of sacrifice and
i think transformation for raya
because that's hope trust forgiveness
they all bleed in
let me take the first step
the ending is is what raya i think felt
that was right finally and when you're
leading the world in anger and
bitterness in in not being able to
forgive not being able to trust then you
can't fully realize what you need to do
and once she lets go of those things
i think that she understands you know
it's a beautiful thing
[Music]
you